اهلا بكم تسلمت وزاره الدفاع العراقيه خمس
مقاتلات روسيه مستعمله من نوع
واعلنت انها ستستخدم في دعم العمليه
البريه للجيش العراقي تزامن ذلك مع اعلان
مسؤول عسكري ايراني استعداد بلاده لمساعده
بغداد بالاساليب ذاتها التي استخدمت في
القتال ضد المعارضه السوريه نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر لنناقشه في محورين
لماذا يحتاج الجيش العراقي الى دعم اجنبي
رغم المليارات التي رصدت له على امتداد
السنوات العشر الماضيه
وما تداعياتها شاشه المنظومه العسكريه
العراقيه على مسار الازمه العراقيه
في غضون اسابيع قليله اكتشف العراقيون اذن
هشاشه جيشهم وشاهدوا قادته وهم يفرون امام
هجمات مسلحين اقل عددا وعتاد ثم ما لبثت
حكومه بغداد ان ظهرت بحاجه جيشها لمزيد من
الدعم العسكري واللوجستي لم تتضح حتى الان
اسباب انهيار هذا الجيش الذي رصدت رصدت له
واشنطن للمفارقه اكثر من عشرين مليار
دولار لاعاده بنائه الا ان مصادر عسكريه
امريكيه اعتبرت ان الفساد والتسيب وغياب
العقيده العسكريه عوامل حالت دون تاسيس
منظومه عسكريه قويه
لم يبقى امام المالكي سوى مقاتلات الروسيه
المستعمله لقتال مسلحين كشفوا عورات جيش
كان من اقوى جيوش المنطقه وافضلها تسليح
خمس طائرات سوخوي تسلمها الجيش الل ستدخل
الخدمه خلال ايام وعلى توضيح الحاله الرفه
للجيش فان مسؤول عسكري عراقيا قال ان
الجيش في امس الحاجه لهذه الطائرات في هذا
الوقت الذي وصفه بال عصيب
لكن لماذا مقاتلات روسيه وليست امريكيه
فذلك ما يكشف معقد واعتبر فضيحه في علاقات
بغداد وواشنطن
فالامريكيون اكتفوا بارسال طائرات من دون
طيار
لجمع المعلومات
ومستشارين عسكريين لكنهم رفضوا اعاده
جنودهم لا قد شككوا الجيش العراقي بعد
الاطاحه بصدام حسين وانفقوا نحو عشرين
مليار دولار على الجيش الجديد مراهنا على
قيام هذا الجيش ب مواجهه التهديدات
الامنيه بنفسه لا ان يعودوا الى بغداد
لجنودهم و دباباتهم وطائراتهم
جناح مسلح للحاكم هناك والحال هذه لم
يتاخر الايرانيون الى اقتراح التدخل
بانفسهم للجنه الرجل ذلك برايهم يقوم على
استنساخ تجربتهم في سوريا على ما نسب الى
جنرال ايراني مع يعني عمليا اللجوء الى
مجموعات مسلحه ذات عقيده قتاليه عابره
للحدود تقوم بمهمات قتاليه باشراف الحرس
الثوري وتحديدا فيلق القدس وقائده قاسم
سليماني فما الذي حدث لهذا الجيش ليصل الى
حافه الانهيار و لاليات وتسليح فاذا هو
عاجز عن التصدي للمسلحين اكتسحوا ثاني
اكبر مدن البلاد وسيطروا على بلدات اخرى
ولم يتقدم زحفهم الى العاصمه نفسها
الامريكيون تقول الاجابه فالفساد وغياب
العقيده القتاليه تكفلت ها بايصال الجيش
الى ما وصل اليه
وبحسب مصادر عسكريه امريكيه فان تفشي
الفساد على نطاق واسع استنزف الاموال
المخصصه للجنود والسلاح وامتد ل يشكل غطاء
لترقيه ذوي الولاء على ذوي الكفاءه وهؤلاء
قاموا بعرض المناصب العليا في الجيش للبيع
كما قاموا بالاحتيال في التعاقدات
العسكريه وسرقوا مخصصات الجنود وملاوا
قوائم الاجور بجنود لا وجود لهم الا على
الورق والحال غادي تحول الجيش في زمن
المالكي والمستفيد من حول الى جيش
استعراضات لا اكثر
موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من بيروت
عباس الموسوي مدير المركز العراقي للاعلام
المقرب من ائتلاف دوله القانون
من دبي الدكتور مهند العزاوي مدير مركز
الثقل للدراسات الاستراتيجيه كما ينضم
الينا من واشنطن هارلين ام كبير الباحثين
في المجلس الاطلسي والمستشار السابق في
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه اهلا بضيوف الكلام
ابدا بضيفي السيد اول ما لاساله عن تفسير
ربما يقربنا من حقيقه ما جرى ما الذي ادى
الى هذا الانهيار السريع في الجيش العراقي
حتى يتم اللجوء الى استعمال ميليشيات من
اجل الدفاع عن الدول العراقيه كما تقول
حكومه السيد المالكي
بدى بدا اعتقد ان تمت مبالغه بوصف الحالات
اليوم لدى العراق اكثر من تسعمائه وخمسين
الف جندي ما شاهدناه في الشمال وان كثر من
الجنود السنه لم يشاؤوا ان يقاتل اه سنه
اخرين وهذا يعني هنالك وجزء كبير من الجيش
وضد المالكي الحكومه حاليا بصدد اه توحيد
هذا الجيش لا نعرف من سوف يحصل بعد
تداعيات اه
الحوادث في تكريت لكن دعونا نواجه الحقيقه
الامر لدينا تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه في
العراق والشام وهي مجموعه مسلحه لكن هذا
يعيدون الى طرح السؤال التالي اذا ما عدنا
الى العام الفين وثلاثه والفين واربعه بعد
ال العمليات الامريكيه في العراق فان هذا
ال اه الجيش اه ايضا كان فيه من ان
فدائيين تذكرون ماذا يعني ذلك وتتذكرون
ايضا ما حدث في الرمادي وغيرها من
المحافظات الغربيه كانت اركان ال قتال
عنيف او كان حتى الامريكيون وجون صعوبات
في اطار ذلك هو ال الجيش العراقي كما
الجيش الامريكي اه يواجه اليوم نفس الحاله
اذا كان الوضع لماذا لجات الحكومه
العراقيه الى استعمال ميليشيات من قبل
مدنيين وتدخلت المرجعيات لدعوه المواطنين
حتى ينخرطوا في الجيش
فيهم الدوله الاسلاميه هو تهديد انتظار
العراق والشيعه وبالتالي الشيعه يريدون
ايضا ان يدافع عن بلدهم واذا كان ذلك يعني
تعاون اكبر مع الحكومه ضد هذا التهديد
الاكبر سوف يقدمون على ذلك سيد الصوره كما
وصفها ضيفنا من واشنطن
فقط مجموعه من السنه خرجوا وبالتالي حدث
هذا الانهيار هناك مبالغه في وصف حقيقه اه
واقع الجيش العراقي الان
تحيه لك اخي الكريم تحرير للضيوف والتحليل
المشاهدين اه حقيقه هذه قراءه سطحيه ما
احتجاجي ضيفك الكريم قراءه جزئيه للمشهد
العراقي ليس هكذا نتكلم عن يعني علق الاخر
تقرير الاستخبارات الامريكيه اليوم او
بالامس على الاقل اه شخص الواقع العراقي
شخص ما ما اه هو اللي داعش تشكل خمسطاشر
عشرين بالمائه من ال من المشهد الحرب في
العراق لا يمكن ان نتكلم عن الا عن فشل
الامريكي في صناعه القوه في العراق نتكلم
عن بناء القوه في وقت اه كانت السياده
مفقوده عام الفين وثلاثه اه بنفس الوقت اه
اه جرى الميليشيات وهذه الميليشيات لا
تتسق بالعقيده الوطنيه ولا تتشرف بالعقيده
المهنيه بنفس الوقت اه هل ت عقيده
التدريبيه من مناشط متعدده وهذه المناشئ
اقل كفاءه من ال القدره والمقدره والمؤسسه
العسكريه العراقيه اضافه الى قواعد
الاشتباك غائبه تماما عن ال القوات
المسلحه العراقيه مع قواعد فيها كافه
القوات وبالتالي لديها خطوط حمر ولديها
تحديدا ت ولديها مساءله ومحاسبه وهذه
نشهدها طيله الضيف يتكلم عن النتائج ولابد
معالجه الاسباب وليس النتائج لانه الاسباب
اللي قاده لهذه النتائج انا اؤكد ايضا
هناك كان امراه طوائف في الجيش وبالتالي
بدات سلوكيات العدد من القوات المسلحه
سلوكيات طائفيه مما يفصلها عن البيئه
والحاضنه الاجتماعيه او ما يطلق عليه
الفضاء الحيوي الاجتماعي وهذا
سني شيعي سيد اه الزوي لا اطلاقا اطلاقا
ليس بهذا الكلام ال احنا راينا في اليوتب
اه انه يعني الاف من ال من ال اه العساكر
الذين سلموا اسلحتهم رفضوا القتال على
الاقل وذهبوا الى الى دورهم القسم من ثوار
العشائر اه اكرم وهم واعطوهم ملابس وذهبوا
الى البيت وهذا يعطينا انطباعا هناك عقيده
غائبه اولا او قد تكون في معركه ليس
معركتهم او الحرب ليس حربهم وبالتالي عشر
سنوات اودع السنه من ال ال ال ال التركيز
على هذه المنطقه واستخدام كافه عوامل
الصدمه والترويع خلق واقع اليوم اللي هو
انفجر بهذا الشكل وبالتالي بالتاكيد الخلل
الخلل في بناء المؤسسات بنفس الوقت
ما الذي ادى الى هذا الوضع حتى يصبح
الدوله العراقيه تستجدي طائرات سوخوي
روسيه مستعمله حتى تهدد ايران بالتدخل
واشنطن طبعا جزء من المنظومه موسكو ما
الذي حدث للجيش العراقي عندما يسال اي
مواطن عراقي اين ذهبت كل الاموال التي
رصدت الجيش العراقي فتكون هذه هي النتيجه
بسم الله الرحمان الرحيم هنا المسلمين
جميعا بحلول شهر رمضان ونتمنى ان يكون اه
شهر رمضان خير وبركه اتصور يعني من من من
البساطه ان نحل للامور ما وصل اليه الجيش
العراقي ونسا رعونه صدام حسين والندوات
التي دخل بها وهجوم على الكويت وح مرحله
الحصار وتدمير الجندي العراقي وعقيده الجي
الجيش العراقي حتى وصلنا الى مرحله
الاحتلال اه بعد الاحتلال عندما حل الجيش
العراقي
وسرقت كل تجهيزات الجيش العراقي فلذلك
عندما نتكلم عن تمويل اتمنى ان نضع ارقاما
لهذا الموضوع لم ترصد اموال حقيقيه اه
يعني عندما نتكلم والذين يريدون ان
يتكلمون و يؤيدون الجيش العراقي بهذه
الطريقه يجب ان يتكلموا عن صفقه اليمامه
التي كانت سرقت بها عشرين او ثلاثين مليار
ان يتكلمون عن الجيش السعودي عندما هزم
امام مجموعه قليله من الحوثيين
سيد موسوي بالمسؤوليه اه الحديث في اتجاه
موضوع الحلقه ولان تفعل موضوعات اخرى
الاعلام عفوا اعتبرني مواطن عراقي يسالك
الان اين ذهبت كل الاموال التي رصدت
عراقيا وامريكيا للجيش العراقي التي ينظر
بها العالم
العراقي عندما يسال السؤال يسال بالمو لا
يسال باستهزاء وفرح هذا اللي نشعر به الان
من اخواننا العرب يستهزئون وفرحين بتدمير
الجيش
على
اعود الى اصل السؤال ما حصل اننا لم نطبق
قانون اجتثاث البعث بحذافيره ما حصل في
العراق وهذه خطانا تحملها كان المفروض
اقصاء كل الضباط البعثيين ما حصل في
الموصل من تسليم الموصل الى الى الى هؤلاء
الدواعش والتكفيريين والبعثيين ومسعود
البرزاني لان هؤلاء الضباط هم انفسهم
الذين تقاعسوا وسلموا بغداد الى المحتل
الامريكي
هذا الواقع الواقع الذي حصل هنالك خيانه
من مجموعه من الضباط امنه الجيش العراقي
لم يبني بعقيده طائفيه لذلك تنوعت
القيادات العسكريه بكل انواعه وما حصل
الذي وصلنا اليه الان علينا الان ان نتكلم
اولا الجيش العراقي لم يصل مرحله الانهيار
الجيش العراقي استعرض الى خديعه اعلاميه
كبيره
ولذلك استعاد زمام المبادره وعاد وما حصل
يوم امس في صلاح الدين من تعاطف من محافظه
صلاح الدين ومجلس المحافظه والعشائر
وابناء صلاح الدين مع القوات الاخرى
وبدانا نحرر المناطق من هؤلاء التكفيريين
لذلك انا اقول هنالك هجمه وكانما احد
ينتظر ان ينقض على الجيش العراقي هنالك
خلل في تسليح الجيش العراقي
هنالك خلل يعني لحد الان
السياسيه
هنالك خلل هنالك فساد هنالك تهاون هنالك
حرص هنالك منظومه تاسست في ظل الاحتلال
وتاسست في ظل ضباط البعثيين خانوا العراق
وكانوا الوطن وبقوا في هذه
السيد الموسوي اشرت نقطه مهمه فيما يتعلق
بطبيعه التركيبه هنا اسال ضيفي في واشنطن
السيد اول ما واشنطن تتهم بانها تتحمل جزء
كبير من المسؤوليه بدايه عند حلها للجيش
العراقي بالطريقه التي تمت
كما عرفه العراق من منعرجات خطيره ثم ما
ال اليه الان الوضع الحالي للجيش العراقي
ما يتهم به من اه فساد ما يرتجى بيتها به
من تسييس وطائفيه في توزيع المناصب واشنطن
تتحمل المسؤوليه
انا اوافقك الراي اعتقد ان حرب العام
الفين وثلاثه كانت سيئه القياده وتوجيه
واه كانت فعلا من اسوء ما شاهدنا لاسيما
حل الجيش العراقي كان هذا خطا فادح برايي
لكن اعود واقول انه
حجما من هذه الصعوبات متصله ايضا بحكومه
المالكي وعدم قدره هذه الحكومه على
الالتزام او الابتعاد عن الطائفيه
وان تشمل هذه الحكومه الجميع بما في ذلك
الشيعه والسنه وايضا الاكراد اه هؤلاء لم
يكون جزءا من الحكومه وما نشهده اليوم في
الشمال وفي الواقع كردستان مستقل وايضا في
الخارج ما نشهده كذلك مع العشائر السنيه
ولدينا نوع من الجنوب الذي يسيطر عليه
الشيعه اعتقد ان ذلك سوف يستمر واعتقد
ايضا ان سوف نشهد حاله من المراوحه لفتره
مقبله ولكن على المدى الطويل فان تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه هي بحد ذاتها يد عناصر
متفجره بمعنى ان فيها عناصر سوف تنقلب على
بعضها البعض من دون ادنى شك الجيش العراقي
اليوم ليس الجيش الذي يجب ان يكون عليه
الفساد قائم صحيح ولكن اكرر مره اخرى ان
تسعمائه وخمسين الف اه جندي وهو في ذلك
الشرطه وايضا
شبه العسكريه والى جانب الميليشيات
الشيعيه كلها متواجده واعتقد ان الحكومه
في بغداد اه اذا ما قدرت على احتواء تنظيم
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه في العراق والشام
وربما الاستياء مره اخرى على بعض المدن
والموصل لا نعرف اذا كان ذلك سوف يحصل لكن
قد نصل الى نوع من الحرب الاهليه للاجابه
على سؤالك تحمل الولايات المتحده قدر من
المسؤوليه لانها دخلت الى العراق للاسباب
الخطا وبعد ذلك اقدم على خطا فادحا طيب في
الجزء الثاني من هذه الحلقه سوف نتناول
تاثير ما يجري ما يوصف به الجيش العراقي
الان ايا كانت اه اسبابه او تفسيره من قبل
هذه الجهه او تلك على مسار الازمه
العراقيه نلتقي بعد الفاصل
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
نناقش فيها الوضع الذي وصل اليه الجيش
العراقي وما يعرفه من اه حال يصفها البعض
بالانهيار في التعامل مع ارحب بضيوفي في
بيروت وكذلك في دبي وكذلك من اه اه واشنطن
ضيفي من بيروت سيد عباس اه اه الموسوي
عندما يتم اللجوء الى ميليشيات الى حشد
الشعبي خاصه لدى طائفه معينه لان ذلك جاء
بناءا على فتوى من مراجع شيعيه
باي شكل قد يؤثر ذلك على مجمل الازمه في
العراق اذا كان الوضع كما وصفته ليس بهذه
الخطوره وان هناك تواصل وساطه بين
البعثيين وان هناك تضخيم اعلامي
اه بالتاكيد هي ليست مجموعات متطوعه شيعيه
فقط اه ما موجود الان مجموعات تطوع
ومجموعات من الضباط الشرفاء من داخل
الموصل ومن داخل صلاح الدين وهم سنه ومع
الاسف نتكلم بهذه ال المصطلحات اه هنالك
انتفاضه عراقيه لنترك ال التحريض الطائفي
الموجود الان قريبا جدا ستكون انتفاضه
عراقيه عربيه في كركوك اهالي كركوك عندما
يستفيقون من ازمه التحرير
نقول نحن لا لا انا اجيب ان الموضوع ليس
هو كما يتصور البعض هي مليشيات ادخلت في
الدوله هي مجموعه متطوعين استنهض وا عندما
شعروا ان هنالك هجمه كبيره على الوطن وعلى
العمليه السياسيه
الجيش العراقي ما يزال بخير لماذا اللجوء
الى هذه الميليشيات
لان لان التهويل الاعلامي الذي حصل وكانما
تصور البعض ان بغداد في خطر ف استنهضت
الطاقات العراقيه للحفاظ على العمليه
السياسيه وعلى العراق لذلك من قام
بالعمليات ال في صلاح الدين هي ليس
مجموعات المتطوعين قد يكون اعداد قليله
جدا شاركت وانما الجيش العراقي وتسليح
التسليح العسكري العراقي هو من قام في هذا
ال في هذا الج ما قام به سلاح الطيران
العراقي هو ليس مجموعه من المتطوعين
بالتاكيد مجموعه من المتخصصين سلاح الدروع
كذلك هو جزء لان جزء كبير من الجيش
العراقي الذي تحرك من المدن البصره
والمناطق الاخرى فبقي المتطوعين للحفاظ
على الامن ال المحافظات او الامن المجتمعي
هي حمله ونصر للعمليه السياسيه اكثر مما
هي حاجه او عدوان اه بدانا نشعر ان البعض
يتصور انه بدانا نشعر ان بغداد ستسقط
والمدن ستسقط لم يصل الوضع الى هذا
الموضوع الى هذا الحد لم يصل الوضع الى
انهيار كامل في المنظومه العسكريه
العراقيه وانما هي حاله نصر اه من كل
ابناء الشعب العراقي للوقوع من الوقوف
بوجه طيب وانت تتحدث اه الموسوي تذكرت
صوره شاهدناها في الايام الماضيه عن اه
صور ل اه مدن باكملها اقليات بعض القاده
العسكريين وفرارهم صوره ربما كانت تعطي
طرقات ما عن حقيقه ال الجيش العراقي وان
سؤالي
في الموصل طبعا وفي كذلك في مدن وبلدات
اخرى في العراق سيد اه العزاوي الذي جرى
في الجيش العراقي السبب الاساسي في منظومه
الفساد التي اوصلت الجيش الى هذه الحاله
حاله التسييس او الطائفيه التي ضربت مختلف
اوجه المجتمع العراقي ومن ضمنها الجيش ما
السبب الاساسي برايك
يعني ب بلا شك السبب الاساسي هم السياسه
يعني مساس الموجودين اليوم في السلطه يعني
وهذه الحواشي الذي تتكلم تحاول ان تبرر
دائما الا خطاب ب يعني الكوارث بالاحرى
وليس الاخطاء ب ب ب اه النظره نرجسيه يعني
نتكلم العمليه السياسيه العمليه السياسيه
العمليه السياسيه هي وسيله وليست غايه
يفترض ان السياسه فن الممكن ويفترض ان
العمليه السياسيه تبني دوله وتبني مؤسسات
بشكل صحيح ما جرى نشر تلك البدايه انه
هناك خلال اول ان هشاشه تشكيل لتشكيل
القوات هناك خلل في قائمه المهام الجيش
يقاتل الى عشر سنوات في حي الجغرافي معين
في حي الديمقراطي معين خلق حاله انفجار في
هذا الوقت لم يكن سابقا الجيش العراقي
مهامه الدخول وسط المدنيين السابق كان
الجيش العراقي لديه قائمه تحديات ومهام
خارجيه للدفاع عن البلد وهذا واجبه
الرئيسي ولم يكن يمتلك سجون يعتقل
للمواطنين ويمارس السلوكيات الطائفيه ويتم
وجود يستطيع ان من خلال يوتا بتقرا كثير
من السلوكيات التي اوصلت ما نحن عليه اه
اه التكلم اليوم ال ال ال يعني محاوله
الهروب الى الامام لا تحل المشكله اليوم
العراق يحتاج اولا فعل سياسي اه ضيفك انا
اتعجب على ضيفه حقيقه من من واشنطن عندما
يتكلم بهالبساطه يكون هناك ميليشيات هناك
اي دوله بالميليشيات مع واحنا سبب مشاكلنا
في العراق الميليشيات والتنظيمات
الارهابيه الوافده هم كلهم
وهم من اوصلوا البلاد الى ما نحن عليه
اليوم نشتري الملف السيناريو السوري ذاته
يوم اليوم يتبنى الى يعني سليمه العراق
هناك ال ال ال الجيش الامريكي مستشار
الروس هناك الايرانيين وهناك الميليشيات
وبالتالي
اما الشرطه في مساله استعداد ايراني لفعل
ما فعلوه في سوريا فقط نقطه فلسطينيه عنها
اسال عنها ضيفي اه في
اتوجه لضيفي في اه واشنطن عن قيمه ما جرى
اليوم بالوصول طائرات سوخوي اه روسيه
مستعمله الى الى الى اه اه الى العاصمه
بغداد
يعني ما الذي يمكن ان تفعله ثلاث طائرات
روسيه في هذا التوقيت فيما يتعلق ب اه او
امس وصلت فيما يتعلق ب اه ما يجري على
الارض او ممكن عمليات
يعني بشكل طبيعي العراق بحاجه الى تسليح
طيران واسهل طريقه هو تعاقدنا مع الاداره
الامريكيه والامريكان يتاخرون ويتركون
بسبب اللوب الصهيوني السعودي الذي يمنع
تسليح العراق في امريكا فلذلك الطيار
العراقي والطيارين العراقيين هم اه يعني
عندهم الخبره الكامله على استخدام السلاح
اه بحاجه الى عدد من الطائرات السوري
والطائرات
وتاتي اه اعداد جيده من هذا لان نحن نشعر
ان الهجوم ال ال اه يعني استباحه الارض
العراقيه من دول اخرى بادوات عراقيه جاءت
لانها تشعر من الجيش العربي ضعيف لو كان
الجيش العراقي قوي لما تجاوزوا على
السياده العراقيه
بغداد
يا اخي
يعني جانب الحقيقه طائرات عمرها اربعين
سنه يعني عمرها الافكار
هو منتهى اذا ما نعم اذا ما اخذ بنظر
الاعتبار انه الطيار يحتاج الى وقت طيب ما
يحتاج الى عمر ويحتاج الى تدريب هذه
الاعمار انتهت بالمستوى الطائرات عندما
نتكلم عن طيارين لابد ان هناك طياري الروس
اتوا مع الطائرات الا هكذا يمكن ان نفكر
وانما تتكلم عن طيارين العراقيين تجري
تجري فهم بالكامل الجاري اغتيال الطيارين
هم وعوائلهم في العراق اه بعض الطيارين
المتواجدين ليسوا على المقاتلات العراقيه
وانت تعرف القوه الجويه العراقيه سلمت
بالكامل الى ايران في عام الف وتسعمائه
وواحد وتسعين لن يجري التدريب بهذا الشكل
على الاخوان لم تكن لدى العراق حتى في
السنوات العشره وخمسه الاخيره هذه المقدره
الجويه وبالتالي من سيقود هذه الطائرات
وهنا الكلام ليس فقط ان تجلب طائرات ما هو
بطبيعه المهمه هي الاهداف هذه الطائرات لا
تعرف عباره عن تيار الطرق والمتفجرات قد
تكون براميل او غيرها وبالتالي لم تكن
مصيبه في الهدف ولم تكن دقيقه بنفس الوقت
طيب سيد اولمن اي دور قد يلعبه الجيش
العراقي بعدما اصيب بهذه الحاله فساد من
جهه وتسييس من جهه ماذا عن دور هذا الجيش
فيما يتعلق بالازمه في العراق
يعني
سوف يكون على هذا الجيش ان يتعلم ما يجب
ان يقوم به بمعنى اخر ال التدريب هو اساسي
يجب ان يتمتع هذا الجيش بفاعليه اكبر ويجب
ان نصل الى هذه النتيجه سريعه لاسيما اذا
ما كان الجيش يريد ان يحقق الاهداف
المتوخات اعني بذلك احتواء تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه
لكن المشكله الاكبر يه وواضح وزاريه هي
متصله تربيه حكومه لا تحظى بشعبيه ويجب ان
تعمل على المصالح بين الاطراف جميعها واذا
لم يحصل ذلك اخشى ان العراق سوف يتجه نحو
حرب اهليه لفتره طويله مقبله قضيه اخرى
يجب ان نعطيها في اذهاننا اه في الواقع اه
التعاون مع الولايات المتحده مع ايران مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه او حتى اسرائيل
وتركيا وروسيا اعني بذلك مؤتمر يجمع كل
هذه الاطراف لكي نعرف كيف نتعامل مع تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه لان هذا التنظيم هو عدو
مشترك لكل هذه الاطراف لاسباب سياسيه
داخليه في الولايات المتحده يصعب على
اداره اوباما اليوم ان تتحدث الى ايران او
حتى ان تقيم هذا النوع من المؤتمر في ضوء
ما يجري في اوكرانيا مع القرم ومع الروس
لكن لابد من الوصول الى حل
لذلك
اشكرك اشكرك سيد اولمن ادركنا الوقت
هارلين اولمن كبير الباحثين في المجلس
الاطلسي والمستشار السابق في وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه كما اشكر ضيفي من بيروت عباس
الموسوي مدير المركز العراقي للاعلام
والمقرب التي لا دوله القانون وكذلك اشكر
ضيفي من دبي الدكتور مهند العزاوي مدير
مركز السكر للدراسات الاستراتيجيه
اذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده
فيما وراء خبر جديد الى اللقاء باذن الله
ام